You can reach out -- things are solid.
You can move objects from one area to another.
You can feel your body.
You can say, "I'd like to go over to this location,"
and you can move this mass of molecules through the air
over to another location, at will.
(Laughter)
That's something you live inside of every day.
Now with the allocation and the understanding
of the lack of understanding,
we enter into a new era of science
in which we feel nothing more
than so much so as to say
that those within themselves,
comporary or non-comporary,
will figuratively figure
into the folding of our non-understanding
and our partial understanding
to the networks of which we all draw our source
and conclusions from.
(Laughter)
So, as I say before the last piece,
feel not as though it is a sphere we live on,
rather an infinite plane which has the illusion
of leading yourself back to the point of origin.
(Laughter)
Once we understand that all the spheres in the sky
are just large infinite planes,
it will be plain to see.
(Laughter)
(Audience) (Laughter)
This is my final piece.
And just remember,
everything you are --
it's more important to realize the negative space,
as music is only the division of space;
it is the space we are listening to divided as such,
which gives us the information in comparison to something other
that gives us the idea of what the idea that wants to be transmitted
wants to be.
So please, without further ado.
(Applause)
Thank you.
This is a fun one.
It goes like this.
(Beatbox)
(Gibberish)
(Music ends)
Okay, for the last piece I'd like to do,
this one goes very similar to this.
I hope you guys recognize it.
Here we go.
Okay, that still works. Okay, good.
All right, here we go.
(Laughter)
(Beatbox)
Here we go.
Yeah, yo, yo, yo
(Gibberish)
(Music fades out)
Thank you. Enjoy the rest.
(Applause)